en 1911 el artista vasily kandinsky
asistió un concierto de arnold schönberg
la revolución pero era un compositor de
música clásica que con su música tonal
revolucionó todo el paradigma de la
música tradicional y es que en el
concierto kaminski se dio cuenta de que
no solamente podía escuchar la música
sino que también podía verla a raíz de
esta necesidad de retratar la música
comenzó a pintar cuadros como éste
tensión suave en tensión suave todo es
una alegoría a la música trato de pintar
y hacer una metáfora de lo que sería la
intensidad del sonido que viene
reflejada por las formas y los
instrumentos que vienen reflejados por
los colores en este caso concreto los
colores más fríos simbolizan los tonos
más graves como los contrabajos mientras
que los tonos más estridentes vienen
reflejados por el tono amarillo
los blancos simbolizan los silencios y
los negros las pausas kandinsky no
buscaba representar una realidad que
solamente él pudiera entender buscaba
que cada persona pudiera interpretar a
su forma este cuadro y pudiera escuchar
su propio concierto buscaba que al igual
él pudo reinterpretar la música otros
artistas cogieron su obra
llevarán a otras ramas del arte y esto
mismo hizo el año pasado el artista y
cocinero chef español paco torreblanca
en colaboración con el museo thyssen
llevó a cabo este postre a base de
chocolate bizcocho y crema suiza elaboró
un postre en el que no solamente se
parece mucho en cuanto a composición y
estética sino que además creó una
simbología con los sabores mediante los
contrastes de sabores trato de que el
espectador el comensal pudiera saborear
un cuadro de kandinsky
creo que a día de hoy el concepto de
espectador ha cambiado mucho y la forma
en la que consumimos el arte recuerdo
cuando fui al museo de arte moderno de
nueva york moma para ver uno de mis
cuadros favoritos la noche estrellada de
van gogh recuerdo que apenas fui capaz
de verlo porque había diez filas de
turistas que con sus padres de shelf y
hacían fotos ráfagas de fotos al cuadro
sin apenas realmente apreciarlo
y creo que a día de hoy estamos muchas
veces turistas que simplemente visitamos
una catedral o un museo que nos viene en
la guía de ocio casi sintiéndonos en la
obligación de hacer fotos a paredes que
el guía turístico nos ha dicho que están
importantes sin embargo tenemos que
entender el contexto del autor y las
influencias que éste tuvo para poder
entender la obra en este caso por
ejemplo noche estrellada
sería interesante entender que van gogh
tuvo esquizofrenia bipolaridad depresión
y epilepsia a esto se suman de que era
adicto a la absenta y entenderéis por
qué terminó en el hospital psiquiátrico
desde donde la habitación de su hotel
tomó este cuadro
en esto es su vida el psiquiátrico
comenzaron a suministrarle digital in a
un medicamento natural que he tomado en
exceso puede llevar alteraciones de la
mente distorsión de la realidad
exaltación del color amarillo y que la
mente genere a los en torno a luces muy
fuertes como pueden ser las luces de una
noche estrellada
al igual que kandinsky van gogh no
buscaba representar una realidad
figurativa que todo el mundo pudiera
entender buscaba representar su propia
versión su propia visión del mundo
esto a su propia manera lo ha hecho un
artista español un fotógrafo uno de mis
fotógrafos favoritos rafael díaz que
lleva a cabo una reinterpretación de
cuadros de historia del arte esta es el
rosetón de santamaría de la catedral de
santa maria de regla en león los
restricciones serán enormes vidrieras
que servían para iluminar la parte más
importante de la catedral los altares y
que servían como un puente que conecta
bolt conectaba el plano más físico y
humano y el plano trascendental y divino
en la reinterpretación de rafael díaz se
trata de un rosario de 85 escáneres para
detectar las enfermedades cerebrales
trata de simbolizar un puente entre
nuestro estado animal y la evolución
humana por medio de la ciencia por eso
este cuadro se llama la luz de la vida y
la ciencia
todo esto me llevó a pensar que
realmente vivimos en una red de
influencias en la que crecemos nos
retroalimentamos y decidimos empezar a
formar parte de ella cuando en el
bachillerato de artes me di cuenta de
que yo podía empezar a formar parte de
ella por eso decidí empezar mi propio
proyecto de reinterpretación de obras
que estaba estudiando en ese momento os
presento a la venus de botticelli la
venus era la diosa del amor y la belleza
pero también era una figura de gran
poder era una figura que podía dirigir a
ejércitos de miles de cientos de miles
de soldados en mi reinterpretación en
colaboración con la artista en la cadena
decidí llevarlo a la fotografía una de
mis pasiones
fueron 8 horas de trabajo y cuando
terminamos al atardecer nos dimos cuenta
de lo que habíamos hecho de las mujeres
nos habíamos juntado para tratar de
retratar lo mismo que había intentado
botticelli la figura femenina
independiente frente al arte por otro
lado también quiero presentaros a otra
interpretación
esta vez la la figura de la mujer es
algo distinta y es que se trata de un
aparato rococó o sea de un retrato
aparato rococó los en esta época las
mujeres con grandes riquezas eran las
únicas que se podían permitir un retrato
por ello solían hacer alarde de sus
riquezas mostrando los cuadros sus
vestidos y sus joyas en mi
reinterpretación no solamente trate de
estimular el mismo contexto la misma luz
y la misma estética sino que trate de
simbolizar lo que es realmente la
riqueza a día de hoy que viene reflejada
en este libro que para mí simboliza la
literatura y la cultura además la
artista de nueva una cadena diseñó este
vestido
inspirándose y reinterpretando la moda
de la época rococó con unos trapos que
tenía en casa un tapete y unas sábanas
viejas hizo este maravilloso vestido y
ahora por último quiero cerrar con una
de las fotografías que más de las que
más me orgullosa me siento se trata de
una obra no inspirada en una obra en
concreto o en un artista concreto sino
más bien influenciado por un concepto el
horror vacui el horror vacui es un
concepto de la época rococó que inspiró
a todo el siglo 17 los arquitectos
músicos y dramaturgos de esta época
tenían miedo a los silencios tenían
miedo a los espacios en blanco al vacío
y por eso tendían a rellenar todos los
espacios con ornamentos y ese creo que
es un concepto que ha resurgido en el
siglo 21 a día de hoy tenemos miedo a
los silencios incómodos a la soledad
tenemos miedo a ahogarnos en la soledad
y por eso tiene tendemos a tomarnos en
una red social y tratar de llamar la
atención
escapando nos con un móvil el arte es
belleza el arte no es simplemente
aquello que a lo que vamos a hacer fotos
rápidamente cuando visitamos una nueva
ciudad no es aquello que está
simplemente detrás de una vitrina o
detrás de los cordones de seguridad un
museo no es exclusivamente aquello que
sale en los libros de historia y nos
empeñamos para sacar un 10 en el examen
el arte es todo aquello que nos hace
sentir podemos ver arte cuando busca
viajamos buscamos el arte buscamos un
rosetón que nos pueda emocionar buscamos
una sinfonía de un compositor
vanguardista que nos cambie la
percepción de lo que es el arte para
nosotros buscamos las croquetas que
nuestra abuela nos hace con tanto cariño
cuando vamos a su casa a comer buscamos
una persona
buscamos un atardecer algo que nos haga
sentir algo arte no es aquello lo que
hacemos una foto rápida para luego
olvidarnos artes
es aquello aquí la esencia del autor que
se queda impresa la obra y que nos
acompaña incluso cuando hemos salido del
museo arte es lo que estamos haciendo
hoy aquí y espero que de alguna forma
podeis reinterpretarlo para aplicarlo a
vuestras vidas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]